[Music]
I'm really excited to be here to talk
about a topic that I personally am quite
passionate about which is taking data as
it's being produced and deriving
insights from that data in real time to
drive business decisions and actions so
over the let me set the agenda of what
we'll cover over the next 45 to 50
minutes this is a 100 level introductory
talk on stream processing on real-time
stream processing with a focus on
business use cases enabled by real-time
stream processing so what we'll do is
we'll cover common stream processing
architectural patterns so I'll highlight
the architectural pattern and for each
architectural pattern I will pair that
with a few real-world use cases that
leverage that pattern so there's a very
pragmatic talk we'll cover pragmatic
patterns and use cases so let me also
talk about what we will not cover what
will not cover is we won't be going
under the hood and look at how the
various stream processing technologies
actually work so we won't look at how
they work we'll look at how to use them
for your use cases will also not be
looking at snippets of code we won't go
to the code level we'll stay at the
architectural pattern level the second
half of this talk is actually what I
suspect will be more compelling to you
we are fortunate to have Sheriff Hadiya
tiller from go Jack come here and join
us and talk to us about various stream
processing use cases business use cases
implemented at go-jek I mean a lot of
these use cases have actually been
implemented by Sheriff who is a data
engineer so we're very fortunate to have
him here to talk about these use cases
go jack is is a fascinating company it
is a fast-growing company based in
Indonesia and they're also they have a
presence in other parts of Southeast
Asia as well they have a bunch of
offerings and I'll let sheriff talk
about go check in more detail but let me
just give you a preview of most of their
their note where the offerings are in
ride-hailing and logistics or delivery
so really excited to have sheriff here
talk about how they've implemented
business use cases that leverage
real-time stream processing and towards
the end we'll leave a few minutes for
Q&A so before we dive into the
architectural patterns let's take a step
back and look at the the big building
blocks for most end to end real-time
stream processing applications so at the
very left we have these sources of data
the applications that are generating the
continuous streams of data that we'll be
processing the first thing you want to
do is take those streams of data and
write them to a reliable scalable high
throughput streaming data Channel think
of this as the the big pipes through
which a streaming data moves and the two
most common options are Apache Kafka
which is a popular open source option
which is available on Google Cloud and
then the other option is pub/sub which
is google's fully managed and serverless
offering well after you've ingested the
data often that that data is going to be
in a raw format not a format that is
amenable for analysis so you want to
take that raw data and transform that
data into a format that is much better
for analysis and you do that in real
time stream processing engines and on
Google Cloud the two most common options
the recommended options are either data
proc or dataflow so data proc is
Google's managed offering for the
popular open source distributed
processing engine Apache spark dataflow
is Google's cloud native solution for
both stream and batch processing and
dataflow is a fully managed and
serverless offering well so after you've
transformed the data now it's it's ready
to be analyzed you can do the analysis
in dataflow or data proc itself both
offer fairly flexible programmatic SDKs
you can do arbitrary analysis and
processing within data flow or data proc
but another common pattern is you take
the transform data and you write it into
bigquery bigquery is our infinitely
scalable fully managed
equal based data warehouse in the cloud
so once the data is written to bigquery
you can issue sequel queries to bigquery
and analyze the data so great at this
point we have analyzed the data and
we've likely derived the insight that is
of interest but the whole point of
real-time stream processing is to make
that insight or the results of our
analysis actionable in real time which
means that that invariably means there
has to be some end user facing
application where the insight or the
results of the analysis are served and
to do that we write the analysis the
system's two data stores that can serve
the data common options here are no
sequel stores such as BigTable and data
store cloud spanner is a transactional
database that is increasingly becoming
popular for stream processing use cases
and of course you can write the data to
bigquery because when a sequel query is
issued to bigquery say through the JDBC
client it immediately serves the results
so you need some system to serve the
results to the end-user applications and
that happens through bigquery BigTable
data store or spanner there other
options as well you can use cloud sequel
and so on and so forth but in stream
processing and these four options listed
here tend to be the common options now I
do want to highlight that on Google
Cloud these tools are seamlessly
integrated so that you can focus on your
application logic and and the api's are
neatly integrated for you to transfer
data from one system to the other three
data and write write data from one
system to the other and the other thing
I want to highlight is most of these
tools are managed and some of them are
server lists and what what I mean by
managed and server list is a managed
offering is one where you as a user do
not have to worry about spinning up
clusters managing clusters managing VMs
and scaling up and down and serverless
offerings are where you can just forget
that there's a cluster in the background
you just submit your workload we take
care of spinning up VMs on your behalf
scaling them up and down and so forth so
it's really compelling because these are
all seamlessly integrated and many of
them are managed and serviced so with
that let's start and dive into some
specific patterns
but but first let me set some context
for simplicity when I talk about a
pattern I will have an architectural
diagram that just focuses on the pattern
and just to keep things consistent we'll
focus on using pub/sub as our default
streaming data channel and we'll use
data flow as our default stream
processing tool of choice I do want to
highlight that in real-world use cases
you will actually be combining a bunch
of these patterns but over here just for
simplicity so when you look at our
architectural diagram it's easy to read
I'll just highlight one pattern at a
time I just want to repeat the
real-world use cases will clearly be a
combination of these and when you look
at sheriff stock that actually become
very apparent and before we move on just
one piece of advice always archive the
raw data with stream processing mistakes
will happen and often mistakes happen
because of errors in user code and if
you've not archived the data it can
become difficult to recover but if you
have archived the data then you can
always backfill recover by running a
batch job and so forth so just a rule of
thumb always be safe archive the raw
data and of course you don't need to
keep the archived data for yours on and
keep it for a few months and then when
you know that you know things have
worked fine you can you know discard the
archived data and often archiving the
data is very little cost
alright so with that let's dive into the
first part and the very first part and I
want to talk about is very simple it
just entails reading the data streams
events that come in and writing them
directly into bigquery Vic query has an
API called the bigquery streaming API
it's a high throughput streaming API and
as soon as you write an event into
bigquery through this API any sequel
query issued to bigquery that after will
have results that incorporate these new
events so in many cases to do real-time
processing of data all you have to do is
stream the data into bigquery as it
comes in of course that would always
work this works when your data comes in
in a JSON format and often you want the
fields of the the records to match the
columns of your table there are
non-trivial use cases where that is the
case you have JSON data coming in at
maps to
feels your table you just write it in
and you're good to go and often
real-time stream processing is as simple
as that and I did mention this is a
pragmatic talk I'm not always gonna you
know get into a sophisticated stream
processing and in many cases this is all
you need and you're good to go but of
course that's not going to be true all
the time in in in most cases you will
need to do some processing of the data
because it comes in in a raw format and
you want to do some transformations to
convert it from whatever RAW format it
came in to some slightly structured
format that is amenable for analysis in
many cases you will get malformed data
and you want to filter out the malformed
data as you doing the transformation and
cleaning you might convert data from
strings to more structured fields like
date/time fields and inns and fields and
floats and so forth so you do that in
cloud dataflow cloud dataflow you can
take the incoming data and process each
event one by one so over here we're
talking about something fairly simple
where you're not looking at multiple
events and aggregation you're actually
looking at each event in isolation and
of course in many cases the events
coming in are not going to have all the
the information you need to do your
analysis so what you need to do in many
cases is join the incoming data with
relevant metadata that will be in other
data stores and in common data stores
that hold metadata our might be in some
bigquery table it could be a sorry
bigquery table it could be in big table
or spanner or even other relational
databases like cloud sequel so you join
the incoming data with relevant metadata
from other data stores you have enriched
your data and now you have your
transform clean filtered and rich data
you write it into bigquery and you're
ready for analysis now I do want to
highlight that systems like data flow
they actually the SDK is provide very
easy to use operators so you merely
invoke the operator to do
transformations or filtering or joins
and often you actually have to provide
just a small snippet of code that
contains your custom logic that
determines what you want to do with the
events so the SDKs make all of this very
easy and of course these systems are
integrated so moving data from one place
to the other is also incredibly easy
thanks to the pre-built api's
now let's talk about business use cases
now when it comes to writing data to
bigquery in real time this is applicable
across industries and business business
use cases this is applicable in any
situation where you're using metrics and
dashboards to run your business which
increasingly is most businesses in many
cases you just stream the data in and
you now are having dashboards so when
you issue a bi query the results reflect
what happened now they're not reflecting
what happened yesterday and I want to
contrast this with what happens
traditionally where you might have a
daily job at an ETL job ETL is the term
commonly used you have an ETL job that's
taking your raw data and doing a whole
bunch of transformations in a batch
format and then loading it into your
analytic data warehouse now don't get me
wrong there will still be use cases
where you need to do that batch
processing because what whatever
analysis you're doing in that job may
not be amenable for a streaming pattern
but if you look at your ETL jobs you'll
find that a significant chunk of those
jobs can be converted to streaming jobs
and if you convert them to a streaming
job dashboards that that are powered by
that data reflect the state of the world
as of now not as of yesterday or as of
last week very cool so now let's look at
a slightly more sophisticated pattern
where you're actually looking at a whole
bunch of events together in many
scenarios what you're interested
particularly when you're talking about
real-time analysis what you're
interested in is what happened in a very
recent or the most recent window of time
what you're interested in knowing is
what happened in the most recent 30
seconds or the most recent say 5 minutes
or maybe even couple hours but the key
thing is you want to know what happened
in a recent window of time and as time
proceeds you want to constantly look and
analyze what happened within the most
recent window and to do that you used
fixed or sliding windows there's a
subtle difference between the two fixed
windows don't overlap so one window ends
and the next window begins and then with
sliding windows you actually have a
large window that moves a little bit
every time so there is overlap across
subsequent windows and depending on your
use case you can use one or the other
essentially you in
VOC you pick the type of window you want
you invoke the window within your code
and you provide another snippet of code
that determines how you want to process
that if the events that fit into a
particular window and then the framework
essentially handles the rest the
framework will handle the creation of
these windows and the collection of the
events that fit into a window and
essentially it'll keep track of time and
as soon as a window completes as soon as
it completes it will call your snippet
of code analyze the events that fell
into that window so the framework
simplifies this windowing process
significantly so now let's look at use
cases that are enabled by this and there
are a whole bunch of use cases let me
start with retail any e-commerce because
they often tend to be use cases that are
easy to understand and empathize with so
with e-commerce let's say you want to
keep track of popular items you want to
know items that are becoming popular as
soon as that that trend starts to
surface and you may not really care
about the popularity of that item last
week or yesterday because you want to
catch trends early so what you do is you
keep track of the searches that people
are issuing in the e-commerce website
and you're analyzing the searches that
came in within say the past couple of
hours and then you know the products
that are popular now and then you can
match that with your inventory to know
if let's just say that the inventory
cannot keep up with the demand or if
demand is higher than the inventory then
you can do dynamic pricing similar use
cases where you might have some product
quality issues a new batch of products
came in and they have some defects so
now you're seeing a high number of
complaints or returns and you want to
capture that very quickly and and when
you're capturing this you're not really
interested in the number of returns or
complaints that came in last week you
want to know what happened in the past
say few hours and again fixed and
sliding windows enable them there's
similar use cases and IT operations when
you're tracking metrics and you can see
how that metric is moving over a recent
window of time and you can also contrast
that with the historical information
it's also particularly common in finance
where for stock trading strategies a lot
of their strategies actually look at
multiple windows of time simultaneously
because they
know how the stock is moving so a bunch
of use cases that leverage fixed and
sliding windows now let's actually one
more use case before we move on there
are certain use cases where you're not
necessarily interested in what happened
in the most recent window what you want
to do is you actually want to do some
smoothing and denoising this is
particularly true in IOT where you have
a lot of cheap sensors and these sensors
are sending information but the
information coming in is is often very
noisy there's a whole bunch of noise and
you don't want to be making big
decisions based on the value of one
sensor reading so an easy way to deal
with that is you define a reasonable
window of time and you just average out
say the sensor values within that window
so that essentially serves as a simple
denoising and and smoothing technique
which is common in IOT use cases and
it's also applied in in similar other
use cases very cool so moving on now
let's talk about fairly distinct but
very popular type of windowing called
session windowing and this is useful for
consumer internet and mobile
applications essentially what session
windowing session windows are used for
is collecting your click logs all the
activity that users perform on the web
application or the mobile application
all that information is streaming in and
what you want to do is isolate each user
session so you can analyze what happened
within that session so this is different
from fixed and sliding windows because
the windows are not fixed and also you
have a separate window per user so all
you have to do is to the in the
framework you just have to mention what
is the field in your incoming events
that corresponds to the user ID and then
the framework will automatically split
the events based on that user ID and
then you have to pass another parameter
which is the duration of inactivity that
signifies the end of a session because
they're you know many ways you know a
session has ended the most common way it
tends to be ok the person is no longer
you know active on my application so
let's consider the session to be done so
you specify these two parameters what is
the key that specifies the user ID and
what is that duration of inactivity that
signifies the end of a session and the
framework handles the rest the framework
will take these events split these
events by ID
a window as has ended and as soon as
that window has ended it will invoke
your snippet of code and and no
surprises here this is used by consumer
internet mobile applications to
understand how users are navigating
through that application because what
you are able to do is get the events
that fell within a sessions you can
actually understand the fact that you
know the user came in may have issued a
search query then clicked on a certain
button stayed on a certain page for a
certain duration of time and so on and
so forth so you analyze each session
right the results to bigquery and now
you actually have an aggregated view of
how users navigated through your
application and this is a very common
use case particularly when you are
deploying new versions of your
application or you're doing a/b testing
you want to identify mistakes soon you
want to identify something you might
have shipped that is leading to a
significant drop in a certain usage
pattern that is critical so as soon as
you run your a B test you have your
streaming job analyzing user sessions
identify issues quickly and maybe roll
back it's a very common use case and and
a fairly distinct use case that was
worth calling out so that was windowing
it's moving along now let's talk about a
topic that is likely to be popular GCP
and and google cloud next machine
learning is clearly a theme of the
conference and and many scenarios you
want to apply machine learning within a
streaming context actually quick show of
hands I am curious to know how many
folks in the audience are interested in
applying machine learning on streaming
data
alright that's that's as I suspected
there's a lot of interest now in this
particular scenario I'm talking about
users training their own custom models
for their use case and that training
that heavy lifting happens in a batch
format and it happens not within the
streaming engine it'll happen in
something like cloud machine learning cm
le which is cloud machine learning
engine that lets you train your own
models in this particular diagram I'm
using tensorflow because that was the
most recognizable logo that I could use
to signify machine learning but of
course you can train other mortals
scikit-learn x3 boost or a bunch of
other frameworks that let you do machine
learning of course the heavy lifting is
happening where you're training a
machine learning model but once it's
trained you can leverage the
train model within your streaming
application to do influence or scoring
on the events as they stream in now of
course before you can do the scoring and
I want to reiterate the fact here that
real-world use case will employ a bunch
of other streaming use other patterns
that we mentioned often before the you
can pass the data to the machine
learning model you will be doing a whole
bunch of transformations joining and
enriching the data from external meta
stores is very common because you want
to fetch features you do the
transformation create the feature vector
pass it to the model for scoring now
some of you may be thinking that this
doesn't sound very remarkable because
you know it's rather simple to take a
machine learning model and invoke it
within the context of a streaming
application and that is true this as an
architectural pattern is not
tremendously remarkable but I wanted to
reaffirm the fact that this is happening
this is a very common pattern and is
actually very easy to implement pattern
and often within your streaming
application you can constantly be
checking to see if a new model has been
produced and when a new model is
produced you take the new model or often
customers even run some a be testing
where they're using bunch of models to
score different events and see what's
happening I assume already affirm that
this is a very easy pattern to implement
with GCP tools particularly when you're
using something like cloud machine
learning engine and customers are doing
it increasingly common pattern and a lot
more customers are doing it so let's
look at a few use cases ecommerce and
finance real time fraud detection that's
sort of the poster child for real-time
stream processing and machine learning
so actually won't beat that horse
anymore
I'll move on there are other use cases
for example digital advertising where
you have all the click and impression
information streaming in all the time
and you can use that in real time to
determine what ads have the highest
proclivity of being clicked so as the
data streams in you apply machine
learning model and you you can determine
what is the right ad to show for
subsequent users that come in now these
are all again fairly I guess relatively
known use cases because digital
advertising has been around for a while
I'm particularly it's gratifying to talk
about use cases in healthcare where
literally lives are being saved
very commonly referenced use case is one
of doing sepsis identification sepsis is
a condition that happens after fairly
invasive operations it's the type of
infection and historically nurses would
have to keep checking in on the patient
periodically to see how they're doing it
to see if they're at risk for sepsis but
now because patients are you know
connected to various devices and you're
monitoring their vital statistics as
that data streams in you can apply a
machine learning model that can
determine who's at risk for sepsis and
if a patient is identified a pager alert
can go out to a nurse so the nurses
don't have to proactively keep checking
and you can offer more proactive care to
the post-operative patients was a
particularly gratifying use case to talk
about now in the previous example the
user had to build the machine learning
model but that's not always true again
if you've you know at next you might
have visited a bunch of talks where we
spoke about our machine learning api is
that do the machine learning for you you
give us the data the images or the
speech and so forth and we apply the
machine learning and return the results
and invoking these api's from a
streaming application is again an
increasingly better common pattern and
again it may seem unremarkable because
they and the heavy lifting is happening
in the machine learning ApS that is
actually true this is come to think of
it a fairly easy pattern to implement
but it's a increasingly common pattern
and just one piece of advice when you're
calling these api is you wanna for
proper performance you want to limit the
amount of data that's going over the
network so commonly what people will do
is they'll use a fixed window or even a
sliding window but often a fixed window
so just to get a group of few events and
then make batch calls to the APS or
rather make calls to the API is with a
batch of data rather than calling the
API each individual time but again this
is a very simple pattern but it enables
some fairly compelling use cases and let
me let me walk through these there's one
use case and these are actually used
cases that customers have implemented
this one use case where if you have
multiplayer online sessions this is
where you know a bunch of folks are
wearing their headsets and microphones
and they're playing say a first-person
shooter a world of warcraft or what have
you they're constantly talking to each
other and they're playing against each
other sometimes these sessions actually
turn verbally
abusive this is a common problem and now
with the speech-to-text api's as that
speech information comes in you invoke
the API you convert that speech to text
and then you convert that text you apply
NLP techniques to identify when it's
becoming abusive and then you can take
corrective action in that session
another use case is finance where for
trading strategies you want to consume
the world text news information about
you know various organizations of the
world Thomson Reuters for example serves
a whole bunch of financial news you want
to consume that news information invoke
NLP API is to identify the entity is
mentioned in the news articles and also
the sentiment of the news article and
that is a rich source of information to
determine trading strategies another
example which is I guess a du jour
example in in today's world is for home
security where you have your camera
feeds security camera feeds coming in
and you can invoke vision api's to
identify entities in the the image
frames and you can use that to
dynamically determine where when there
might be a physical threat outside the
security cameras outside your home and
so forth so very cool simple pattern but
very useful pattern now the last part I
want to talk about is a slightly more
sophisticated pattern than the other
ones we've discussed so far
it's called stateful streaming and this
is a pattern where as the events flow by
your maintain maintaining some state
information about the entities in your
events and you're using that state
information to take some business
position and again the key thing here is
the framework really simplifies this it
gives you API is where based on a key
such as a user ID you can add state
information and that information is kept
in memory you can add state information
you can read the state information and
take action or you can update that state
information so you as a user often just
have to read snippets of code to do the
add V lookup and update operations and
then the framework handles the rest the
framework will make sure that this state
information and it can be arbitrary
information it's up to the application
to decide what is maintained it's the
framework will make sure that this
information is maintained in memory and
is available in a performant fashion so
and these are often distributed
application so it'll make sure that
fault
discovered that as if a VM goes down for
example the state information isn't lost
the framework will take care of that so
you as a user just have to focus on your
lookup update operations often let me
just talk about one use case where this
is used in the use cases ecommerce where
you have click events and events that
tell you about the activity of the user
on the e-commerce website as these
events come by you can keep information
the user for example search for these
products the user added a certain
product to that cart removed a certain
product for the cart and so on and so
forth and based on that information as
the next event comes in you can
dynamically determine how to personalize
the experience of the user so you can
dynamically determine for example that
hey the user removed an item from the
cart but is still searching for similar
items let me give them an offer or let
me dynamically adjust the
recommendations that are made for
similar products and so forth so that's
what stateful stream processing enables
and there are other use cases as well
for example we have a customer where in
mobile gaming they're dynamically
customizing the difficulty level of the
mobile application when they identify
that a user is getting stuck so whole
bunch of streaming patterns and and we
did a whirlwind tour of common patterns
and next please join me in welcoming
sheriff to stage and talk about go-jek
and how they're using real-time stream
processing thank you
so good afternoon everyone I'm sheriff
from Gajic I'm not a engineer from Joe
Jack in a bi and today I want to share
with you about the real-world examples
of kojic using data flow as our data
streaming and patch pipeline so COGIC is
internation own technology startup that
has specialist in transport for delivery
and payment and kojak's started in 2007
2010 with only call center with no
application we created object services
object is like read Helen surface
motorcycle in Indonesia and in 2015
Kojak launched an app with only three
services we have Co Mart we have Co food
and Quran itself and in 2016
Kojak have expansion in 50 big cities in
Indonesia and create new services since
and this is our application our surface
by now we have currently 18 products
serving very different needs and this is
collect food pills nationwide currently
we have 1 million driver which completed
3 million chips per day and our
application ordered to noted more than
76 million Toone loads and we have more
than 200 thousand merchants in 50 big
cities in Indonesia and we moved to our
consecutive growth so in bi this is our
current step in second quarter of 2018
from the previous month
until this one our creator of data
growing more than 30% from per month and
from the data we can create more than
700 multi-resolution datasets and from
that we can create more than 20,000 data
points from our data analysts we can
they create the meta base and tableau
sheets and from there they create more
than 13,000 data base car and double
sheets and our user which means our
analyst credit the user is more than
2,000
moment and this number are increasing
day by day it means we need more big
platform and more scale for that day so
what is sharing for what is the
challenge from the previous
architectural we have previously we use
Pacific well Pentaho and also the paddle
script and the previous profuse
architecture we have a report at the day
plus one so we couldn't identify the
problems at the moment and we already
also had had concern about the bosnian
power because that occurs in patch and
it already big so we need to process
offer two billion data in one shots
because it's big so we need a bigger
machine with bigger on that because cpu
and we need takes a long time to process
the data and the business needs more
real-time data insights so previously we
use most basic well as you may know that
pasta sequelae needs maintenance daily
weekly monthly at least you have to
archive your data you have to vacuum
your data and you have to index your
data to remain your very fast and you
also need to yeah
maintaining the position server itself
and we also use the Pentaho and pattern
script to to our atl patch which comment
by the air flow then what's next we move
to our tcp platform and what we want is
we want high performance capability with
minimal operational maintenance using
data flow with marcra neural data with
high fellow city and less London's using
stream processing and we want to Apple
to soft with these problems with
real-time data insights so at the moment
we stack driver to Motorola Rock jobs
and the machine and we
CCS for our data leak we use bigquery as
our analytical purpose database we use
pops up to deliver our streaming message
and we use data flow for our streaming
data pipeline so we move to the use case
before we move to the use case I want to
show you about the go check goals so
what is Kaushik goes the Gaggia calls is
on the roster metric so what is north
parametric north automatic is something
that you want to align with the
organization behind
so the entered only knows what
conventicle is so at Gajic that would be
complete booking transactions so what is
metrics that matter when we want to
increase the composite beginning
transactions we have also to increase
the total bookings we have also need to
consider about the allocation and reduce
the cancellation rate total bookings is
the bookings that credit by the customer
and the allocation is something that we
want to align about the customer and the
driver and the cancellation rate is when
the customer created the booking the
driver couldn't complete it and for that
use case I want to show you that when
the allocation is mismatch between the
driver and the customer the combat
bookings would wouldn't be reached so
how to rebalance supply and demand and
how do we view it in real time so this
is the project supply demand use case so
as a user I want to know which location
have mismatch levels of supply demand in
real time and I want to know the
particular trailers are please on the
real time editor aggregation so if you
see the map in front of you if I hover
our pointer in the small dots we just
try for I can know the tray for title
information according the name the plate
number and also the rating of the tray
for itself and I want to able tone it if
I prefer in
the main area to move to hide him in
area so this is after this question is
the pipeline we already made and as you
know we have so many pipeline here we
have three big pipelines in here with
one is streaming to click on pipeline
the second one is dimensioned pipeline
from the bigquery and stream tray for
location pipeline we got from the pub
sub tray for locking show lock or the
driver ping for your information our
driver ping is created time every 10
seconds it means and that day we more we
have more than 10 billions data pings so
from the Civic putting pipeline we
consume from our pops up booking lock or
messages and we created model which
grouped by the su ID and also the status
and we used sliding window as an
animation before the sliding window we
are only concerned about the current
window and weak filter with only created
status and the dimension pipeline we
query from the query we call from truth
table location table service Allah
trouble and also the traffic profile
each of them will create age motel and
will be refresh or windowed pertain and
on trim driver obligation pipeline we
consume from pub sub preferred location
lock and we created a model and we use
fixed window and after there all of them
will be joined and will be stored to our
strong stream hemlock memory store and
our API will call the stream or memory
store and we'll create the mapping from
this and we move to implementation for
the implementation we only focus about
the how we could so which is good the
data we just got the pipeline using the
aperture beam SDK and we deploy to the
data flow as data flow and that's it
we didn't sphere very machine any
cluster or stackdriver what we have to
do is just push the the code to the
aperture beam and about a beam will do
the rest like
creating the machine and create a
pipeline field for us and also the
spectra for by default and this the
pipeline implementations that already
happened
as you can see this is the auto skill
capability of dataflow which means we
can data flow gain skill from one worker
to Sarah Walker based on how big your
data and hope your processing is and
this is scatter my implementations is
for fast forwarded actually refresh in
every minute okay so the idea of the
inside in here we got that the
reciprocal done last long
which is good because the booking might
be big in this area but not for a long
time because the driver took the order
immediately so the the aggregated
booking the credit will be disappear in
the after several minutes but that
insect is not enough how if in the past
equal area there are so cancelled
booking happen in that day so if there
are many booking it can be completed or
cancelled how can we make sure that
every booking is completed not conserved
so that's why we created extended use
cages and this is our estimate these
cases to cancellation aratus kiss
previously we got this chart and the day
after a day plus one and we couldn't say
that oh there's something happened
yesterday there's a spike of
cancellation yesterday but why was that
happen but that was too late because
that was yesterday and maybe today it
not happened so as a user I want to be
notified when there's huge cancellation
at that time so I can determine the root
cause and fix it as soon as possible
you know this pipeline before these from
our menus kiss from this use case I want
to show you that in a pudgy beam we can
create a fan out from this previous
pipeline so we don't create pipeline
from scratch what we have to do is we
have to concern about the stream booking
Kong pipeline only because we don't care
about the dimension pipeline and this
dream trip stream plate for location
pipeline so we movie dot and after we
created the model which is crewed by
booking status and s2 ID we create a
find out to sing to pops up to new
stream and will be consumed by our
cancellation pipeline and the result
will be like this is the our stack
driver
as you may see for example if the
threshold of castle booking is more than
10% of total booking it will give a lot
of they give the alert and after it go
up the threshold will give us the alert
like this alert Castle cook is more than
10% but again that's not enough how do
we know the reason after we get the
alert so what I couldn't do anything
about it we have to know the reason
behind the castle booking and these
there are another use case again so as a
user I want to know the reason castle
booking in real time and I want to have
to notify myself and the merchant if
item may be sold out or maybe the price
difference with apps and current store
or maybe story is closed out of the
scheduled and this is the new pipeline
that will create it we still consume
from our pops up booking lock we filter
status by the castle only and we create
the different motel we created back
route by there as to ID and the castle
reason and we use fixed window and then
we sing to the our pub subtotal stream
and we created notification system and
also this pop one can be synced to our
pay queries so our analysts can
determine the
their result better so this is the JSON
format that we sing to the pops up
downstream it includes s to ID s to ID
and the merchant name and also castle
reason and how many it happened in that
day so after the use cases to use cases
I want to share with you about the three
takeaways that or little version about
using data flow we data flow we can
create a streaming data processing we
are able to solve the same problem with
real-time data insight and data flow it
was high performance scalability with
minimal operational maintenance as you
already get that data flow can scale
from one to several workers based on how
big your data and how complex your
processing is and our report will be
different less than a day so our analyst
can do more getting more insight with
more recent data and that's all for me I
will back to you Anna
thank you very much thank you sir
please do stay on stage so it's always
useful and quite fascinating to hear
about real implementations from
customers and I guess one thing I want
to highlight which was particularly
fascinating was the fact that they built
one complex use case and then they found
out Oh guess what
I can take what I've implemented and
with small tweaks converted into a new
use case so that was quite fascinating
and and the tools on GCP do enable that
easily so if you want to learn more
please point your browser's to this URL
so essentially cloud.google.com
solutions under the big data category
streaming analytics and and from that
website it has links to other deeper
information that you might want to that
you that you want to get access to so
please do direct your browsers to that
website and with that thank you for
listening to our talk we hope it was
useful for you
[Music]